[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: My name is Reto Meier, and I'm
the tech lead for the Android developer relations
team.
In today's session, I will hopefully be able
to provide you guys with some tips which will
help to turn your good apps into great apps.
Now, I consider this to be a follow-up from
my I/O session last year, which was Android
Protips, making this Android Protips II, Electric
Boogaloo.
Like last year, I'm going to try and keep
things pretty technical.
There will be code.
So if you're not comfortable reading code
snippets, don't worry.
I will give you this signal (indicating),
which is your queue to put on your headsets,
start watching Transformers.
So what makes a great app?
Well, in my view, a great app is one where
users aren't even thinking of it as an app.
They're not thinking, am I using an app on
a smartphone connected to the Internet over
a 3G network.
They just want to perform an action, they
just want to use a service.
Whether that's been clicking an icon, selecting
a notification, clicking something on the
home screen, they just want to get something
done and your app is just the way that happens.
So the idea here is to make them not have
to think about the implementation.
They don't have to think about how you've
done it, how the device is connected.
Everything just works.
Let me give you an example of what I mean.
A couple of years ago, I had the very good
fortune to visit Kenya.
Over in Africa, mobile's a serious business.
I don't mean serious as in finding the best
noodle bar in Nairobi.
I mean serious as in this is the only way
you get online.
I mean serious as in you go to a bar, you
see a cute girl or guy, and instead of sending
them over a few drinks, you buy them mobile
phone credits so they can give you a call
if they're interested.
Now, if your smartphone is the way you get
online and it's the way that you flirt, a
really interesting thing happens to your perception
of that device.
Let me give you an idea of what I'm talking
about.
While we were over there, a big part of our
G Africa or G Kenya event was finding out
and talking about the massive growth in smartphones'
innovation and penetration across Africa.
So it was kind of surprising to hear that
a lot of people didn't self-identify as Internet
users on their smartphones.
We asked around, "Do you use the Internet
on your phone?"
"No, not really."
Well, that's strange.
"Why did you buy a smartphone if you're not
using the Internet on it?
Do you not search for things and check your
email and update your social networks?"
"Yeah, of course.
Of course I use Google and Gmail and Facebook.
I just don't really use the Internet."
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: So what's going on here?
Well, it's actually a really interesting phenomenon.
And it's particularly the case in Africa where
most people are starting to get online for
the first time using their smartphones.
So people aren't thinking of these apps as
being really efficient ways of displaying
a Web page on a phone.
They just are thinking of that's something
I can do with this device.
And that's becoming increasingly the case,
even here, where a lot of the most popular
apps don't have Web sites.
And if they do, people don't visit them.
The entire experience is on the phone.
So how big a deal is this?
Well, while we were over in Kenya, we like
to visit some of the phone stores to find
out what phones are selling, what kind of
tariffs, what's the deal.
And we found that you can get the same phone
on basically the same tariff, and on the one
hand, you can get unlimited social networking
updates.
And on the other hand, unlimited Internet
access.
For the same price.
And the interesting thing is, the unlimited
social networking updates was actually a more
popular plan.
And so what we're seeing is people completely
oblivious to the fact that it's the Internet
that powers this stuff.
I'm sure if they thought about it, they would
realize.
But the key here is that you've made that
disconnect.
People are no longer thinking about how these
things work.
It's just something that they want, and updating
their social networks is something they do
a lot, so that becomes really valuable.
So then how do we, as developers, create an
app that's more valuable than the Internet?
Well, it helps if you've already got a service
that people really love, a service which they're
already taking advantage of, and it's something
which they would use as a purchasing decision
when figuring out what phone, what tariff,
what plan to use.
Now, most of us in this room probably aren't
in that boat.
We don't have the existing biggest service.
What we're trying to create is the next biggest
service, the next biggest app that everyone
has to have on their phones.
And I think a really good approach to being
able to create that app is to build something
that works as though it were an indispensable
part of the phone.
So something that doesn't drain your battery,
something that's not obnoxious, that still
provides all the information you need exactly
when you need it, but other than that, it
stays out of the way.
And at the same time, it has to be absolutely
reliable.
It has to be something that users can take
for granted so they're never asking the question,
should I do this?
Should I have a fallback?
Because if they have a fallback in case your
app doesn't work, they're just going to start
using the fallback instead.
So I'm going to look at each of these topics,
invisibility, efficiency, and reliability
in more detail throughout -- throughout my
session here.
So if I seem a little bit nervous now, it's
because I've got a video queued up.
And if you saw my session last year, I had
a little bit of trouble there.
So it's with a small amount of apprehension
that I queue up the first of these interstitial
videos.
[ Video.
]
(Beeps).
[ Laughter ]
(Lip-smacking sounds).
(Noises, siren).
[ Video concludes.
]
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: Thank you.
I can't take any credit for the videos.
But thank you.
So invisibility.
It's obvious why the Droid wants to be invisible.
But why do we want to make our apps invisible?
Is this something we want?
I think it is.
And let me explain why.
So two things happened to me at about the
same time.
I started working for Google, and shortly
before that, I got my first Android phone,
a T*Mobile G1.
Do we have G1 owners past or present in the
crowd?
I/O audience never disappoints.
You've all been upgraded today.
Those two things happened.
As you know, the G1 had the Gmail app, wonderful
app.
What you may not be aware of is that when
you start working at Google, you start receiving
email at a rate of around 1,000 messages a
second, give or take.
And so to try and triage that fire hose of
information, I would check my email every
morning as I commuted into London from Wimbledon
along the district line.
So if you've ever had the pleasure of enjoying
that particular journey, you'll know that
your Internet connectivity goes from kind
of spotty and intermittent as you go in and
out of tunnels and stations until you get
to Earl's Court, London underground proper
and your Internet connectivity disappears
entirely.
Now, the beauty of the Gmail app is that I'm
totally oblivious to this.
I'm checking my email.
I'm reading them, hit archive, it disappears.
Send a message, and it goes.
And I never have to think about whether or
not I'm connected.
By the time I get back to my desk, open up
your laptop, my inbox is synced, my sent messages
have all been dispatched, I'm ready to go.
And I've never had to think for a moment,
how does Gmail work?
How is it sending my emails?
Is it connected to the Internet.
This is in direct contrast to one of the news
apps that I've been trying to use at the same
time.
So I could see the headlines easily enough.
But if I were to click one to try and read
the article, if I happen to be in a station,
it wouldn't load, or if I go through a tunnel,
then I'll get about halfway done and it will
stop.
So I'd be lucky if I could read more than
one or two articles by the time I got into
work.
And that's the same kind of frustration as
I feel when I navigate to a location and then
I look up the venue in an app, and as I'm
walking down the stairs, I go to check in
and it's telling me, you don't have an Internet
connection, so you can't -- try again later.
It's like, well, I want it now.
I'm really not going to bother.
Straightaway, I've had this disconnect.
I'm thinking about how does this app work,
it needs an Internet connection and I'm indoors
now, so I don't have a cell connection.
I should try and get Wi-Fi.
And it's a total disconnect.
It makes me have to think about how the app
was written instead of what I want to do,
which is simply check in.
So how do we create apps which are invisible,
which let us completely ignore how they're
put together in the same way that Gmail works?
Well, the solution is to use something like
this, a queue and send pattern.
Now, the thing about this -- so let's have
a look at this.
Before I go into the details on the code,
please note that all of the code snippets,
slides, and everything else will be made available
within 24 hours of this.
So don't try and copy any of it down.
But let's have a look at the code.
So what we're trying to do here is, we check
to see whether or not we're connected.
And if we're not connected, as in this case,
then we're simply going to add our transfer
to the queue.
So in this example, we're looking at a check-in.
So if we're not connected, that's it.
If we are connected, so looking at this next
section, then we're going to try the check-in
first.
If the check-in fails, then we're going to
add it to our retry queue.
Once we've done that, we're going to go through
that retry queue, which includes anything
we've queued up beforehand before we connected
to the Internet and anything which has previously
failed.
Anything that succeeds, we remove it from
the queue and check to see whether or not
there's anything left in that queue.
If there is, then we're going to need to try
this again later.
Now, in this instance, I've created a fairly
simplistic retry mechanism, which is just
going to use a set interval to continue to
retry.
Now, this isn't particularly efficient.
I'm going to give a much better example later
on of how you should probably do this.
But for the purposes of this code snippet,
it gives you an idea of the process of what
you should be doing.
Note also at the top, when we're not connected,
we're also going to cancel this retry alarm.
There's no pointed in waking the advice and
trying this again if we don't have an Internet
connection.
And, similarly, or in relation to that, we're
also going to enable a manifest receiver,
which is going to listen for connectivity
changes, so that when we do get back on the
Internet, we can straightaway go through this
queue-up queue and perform all of those transfers
straightaway, so you don't have to wait for
the user to initiate another action first.
So that's one way of being invisible.
Another approach is to make sure that your
app feels consistent with the rest of the
framework.
Now, you want to be original, you want to
be creative.
You want to have something which people are
going to recognize and identify with your
app.
But you don't want to have to give them that
moment of cognitive dissonance when they're
trying to figure out how to use your app,
how does it fit into the system.
So the real trick is to create something that
is consistent with the framework aesthetic
but still has that creativity, still has that
uniqueness that represents your app.
Now, the first step to that is to visit the
design site at developer.android.com/design,
that has always the details you need both
in terms of the specific implementation deals
as to how you should make your apps work,
but also the philosophy behind it.
So you can think more about how are the Android
designers thinking, how do they come to those
conclusions?
I'm not part of the design team, so I'm not
going to go in at any length here.
But happily, they will all be here tomorrow,
basically all day, down in room 9, giving
sessions, interactive code labs, all of those
sorts of things to try and really help you
guys get a feel for how they think, the decisions
they've made, why they've made them and how
you can create something that, as I say, is
unique and identifies your app but still allows
users to understand how they work without
having to spend a lot of time on it.
So what else can we do?
Well, I look at some of the most popular apps
and you look at things like Shazam, Instagram,
they're hugely successful.
And I think a big part of that is because
they've created something where it's tightly
bound to an action.
So whether that's recognizing what music is
playing or taking hipster photographs, you
recognize that action.
You associate it with their particular app.
And that's a really powerful thing.
That's how you get to that point where people
just want to be able to do that.
And they don't care how it works.
One of the real advantages to building something
which has that kind of tight focus is it makes
it much easier to then port it across a variety
of different hardware.
Now, this is important, because the Android
ecosystem is huge.
You've got this huge variety of devices both
in terms of variations on smartphones and
tablets, but also an increasingly wide and
diverse ecosystem in general.
So most of us have spent a lot of time developing
for smartphones.
And that's where a lot of our focus lies.
Now, smartphones have all of the new gadgets.
They've got all the sensors, they've got NFC,
they've got touch screens, gyroscopes, front-
and back-facing cameras, the works.
And so it makes sense to develop your app
to take advantage of all of that hardware.
But then what happens when new hardware comes
out?
You've all got a Nexus 7, you've probably
noticed it doesn't have a back-facing camera.
What does that mean to us as developers?
Well, the easiest step is to say, well, my
app takes advantage of all these different
sensors, so I'm going to add lines to my manifest
which says it requires an accelerometer and
NFC and everything else I take advantage of.
Then someone releases a device which is slightly
different, and suddenly your app isn't going
to be available in Google Play, and you're
cutting off what could be a significantly
large portion of your potential user base.
Now, you want to avoid this.
And so let's have a look at a couple of examples.
So for -- if you've got something like an
accelerometer, something like a compass, which
depends on an accelerometer to figure out
which direction you're facing, it's pretty
easy to say that is a required hardware feature.
What if you have an app which lets you apply
filters to photos?
Do you need a camera for that?
Well, most of these apps you don't, because
you can apply those same filters to photos
that are already on the device or that are
in your gallery.
But by simply adding this service requires
users feature to your manifest, or even in
the case of camera, just using the users permission
and not saying that the camera is optional
will prevent that app from being available
to these devices.
So a much better approach is to use the Package
Manager to see what hardware is actually available
at run time.
So rather than blocking your app from a potential
user, what you're doing instead is saying,
well, the user experience is going to be different.
So that can be something as simple as saying,
well, if there's not a camera, then I'm going
to disable or even hide, remove, the take
a picture button.
That makes sense.
But it could be something much more dramatic.
So you may say, well, if there's no touch
screen on this device and no sensors, then
I'm going to try and present more of a lean-back
experience, something where I'm expecting
people not to interact with this app as much.
And so by using this Package Manager class
at run time, you're able to figure out exactly
what hardware is available and really customize
that user experience to present the best possible
way of being able to do things.
It really comes down to, rather than trying
to say how do I lay out my screen on these
different size devices, instead, what you're
figuring out is, given this hardware, how
can users best perform the action which they're
expecting to be able to do with my app?
So it all gets back to this simplification,
making it invisible, making it more accessible
for your users.
So that's invisibility.
I'm going to move on to the next section now
and spend a fair amount of time on this, because
it's a topic that's really close to my heart.
I think efficiency is really important for
users.
So let's have a look at the video.
[ Video.
]
(Ringing noises).
[ Video concludes.
]
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: So efficiency.
We all know that efficiency is important.
It's one of the key tenets of programming.
So it's a huge topic.
And today, really, I want to focus specifically
on efficiency in terms of improving the battery
life of your apps or reducing the impact on
the battery life from your apps.
And even more specifically, I want to look
at how your use of the cell radio, so the
way in which you transfer data, can impact
on your battery life.
You guys already know about my email habit.
I absolutely require email access all the
time.
And if you add to that apps like Pandora,
Google Music, maps, all the other things which
I take for granted, if I don't get eight to
12 hours of battery life out of my phone,
it's a serious inconvenience.
I can see a few folks in the audience, you're
thinking eight to 12 hours, is that a Jelly
Bean feature?
Are you running Cyanogen.
It's none of that.
Really, the way I achieve it is, I'm absolutely
brutal when it comes to removing apps that
disproportionately drain my battery.
So if I install something, look at it once,
and then find at the end of the day my battery
life hasn't lasted as long as it did before,
I'm going to remove the new app.
It doesn't matter how useful it is, it makes
my entire phone less useful, and so it's going
to go.
And when you're performing that analysis,
figuring out which apps are the worst offenders,
it turns out that the way that they use the
cell radio is actually a big impact.
And you can see that when you've got your
cell phone on and you're using cell data,
it can be a significant battery drain.
So how do we impact that?
How do we reduce the impact of that battery?
A big part of that is quite simply transferring
less data.
So smaller pay loads, less-frequent updates,
just generally send less data.
Now, I'm going to look at a few specific techniques
for improving that side of things as well.
But first, I just want to think, is there
anything else we can do?
Does the timing of your transfers impact the
battery life?
Turns out, happily for the length of my talk
to the answer is yes, it can impact it.
And it results in a scenario that I like to
think of as the cookie Droid conundrum.
So I like the cookie Droid, we need to think
to ourselves, would we prefer one big cookie
or lots of little cookies?
Or to put it in slightly more practical terms,
do we want to have as many -- have lots of
little downloads so that we're only downloading
data that we absolutely need, never downloading
anything we don't?
Or do we have one -- or as few downloads as
possible, we're downloading lots of information,
potentially more than we need, in order to
have fewer downloads overall?
A quick straw poll.
Who likes one big cookie?
All right.
And who's into lots of little cookies?
And who thinks we should just go like the
cookie Droid and eat all the cookies?
Yeah.
Sadly, my metaphor does not extend that far.
So we're going to have to look at the two
remaining options that we have.
So the little cookie at first glance seems
like a fairly good approach.
You're not going to download anything that
you don't need.
So you're minimizing bandwidth.
You're not processing anything that you don't
need, so you're going to save some power on
the device that way.
And, really, what it comes down to is, you're
going to put everything off until the last
minute.
You're not going to do anything until you're
absolutely certain that you need to do it.
And that's an approach that I used pretty
extensively getting through college.
Now, --
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: -- as it turns out, both in
terms of college grades and in terms of cell
radio efficiency, it's actually not a very
good idea.
It's just going to cost you more in the end.
And a much better approach is to use this
big cookie model, minimizing the number of
times that you touch the network, the number
of times that you have to perform these downloads.
And to understand why that is the case, you
need to understand a little bit about the
way that the cell radio works.
So this is a really simplified version of
a typical 3G cell radio.
And it works this way.
So you start off in standby mode.
And every time you try and start a new connection,
transaction data, it's going to take around
two seconds -- this varies, but around two
seconds -- to bring the radio up to full power,
at which point you can start transferring
data.
Now, if this is a browser, you can imagine,
this isn't a great experience.
If every time you click a link, hit refresh,
hit some JavaScript, you need to wait two
seconds before the radio powers up and you
can even make the request, let alone download
the data, let alone render the data.
And so to try and account for that, the cell
radio will stay in a full-power state for
some amount of time, typically somewhere between
five and ten seconds, and what we call a tail
time.
So within that time frame, the radio is still
kept in high-power state, so you have latency
if you want to perform further transactions.
After that tail time has expired, you go into
this low-power state, draw about half as much
power, and the latency is going to be reduced.
It's still going to be there, but it's going
to be significantly reduced.
Now, we're going to stay in that low power
state for somewhere between ten seconds to
a minute.
And, again, if nothing happens after that
period of time, we go back into standby state,
where we're not drawing current, but we've
introduced this latency.
Now, the specific tail times are going to
vary based on carrier.
So that's going to be not just carrier, but
location, so East or West Coast, different
countries, different carriers, different usage
patterns for their customers and everything
else.
And so AT&T has a -- timings like this: Five
seconds for high-power tail time, 12 seconds
for low-power.
Vodafone has also five seconds for high power
and a full 30 seconds.
Now, I should point out that there's no better
or worse.
These are just different ways in which these
companies have figured out the most efficient
patterns for their users in those locations.
And it goes on and you can imagine it's the
same for Verizon, and T*Mobile and everyone
else.
So how do you, then, as a developer figure
out the best frequencies, the right timing
to do your downloads in order to have minimal
impact on the battery?
Well, everyone here is an engineer, so I assume
everyone's familiar with fast Fourier transforms.
So we're going to start with this basic equation.
And then what we want to do is, for each carrier,
find the square root of the sum of the squares
of those delta tail times, divide that by
pi.
So who's still with me?
Got a couple.
It's very impressive, because this is totally
made up.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: If you can see my afterwards
and explain, that would be fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: So like I said, this is irrelevant.
You don't -- it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what the different tail
times are.
It doesn't matter what the variation by carrier
is.
All you need to know is that every time you
touch the Internet, every time you make a
connection or do a transfer, you're potentially
going to continue draining battery for a full
minute.
Just think about that.
So if you touch the Internet just to do a
ping, just to say, yes, someone is still looking
at this page, the cell radio is going to stay
on and continue draining battery for up to
a minute.
This is much easier to understand if you have
a look at the visualization.
So what you have here, in blue, the blue line
graph represents network traffic for my app.
And so you can see the little periodic updates,
about every 15 seconds, and then we have these
larger sort of intermittent transfer.
So this could be a news app, where the periodic
transfer is analytics.
We're keeping track of what page, what articles
people are reading at all times so that we
can get a feel for what the most popular news
articles are.
And the intermittent transfers, they may represent
someone clicking an article, all right.
So they want to read the full text, you click
it, download it and read it.
What's more interesting is underneath.
That represents the cell radio state.
Now, blue is an active transfer.
This is when we're actively sending and receiving
data from our server.
Red is that tail time, that high-power tail
time where the radio is still drawing full
current, but we're not actually transferring
anything.
And that will last for around five seconds,
in this instance, exactly five seconds.
So you can see right at the beginning it was
on.
Then we started another transfer straightaway.
So it's continued in that high-power state.
If five seconds elapse, it will turn yellow.
That's when we're at that low-power state.
And it will stay there for a further ten seconds,
assuming no one performs any transfers.
Now once that time has elapsed, you'll go
back to the idle state.
And that is represented here in green.
Now, you probably notice the problem.
There is no green.
Right?
So the entire time that this app is running,
it's drawing power from the battery.
And you can see, it gets worse than that.
Because even just this section in the middle,
where it's just the periodic transfers, we're
still never going green.
So even without the user doing anything, you're
still going to be drawing current, reducing
your battery life, just by having the app
open.
Now, this is exactly not what you want.
So how do you solve this problem?
Well, I like to think of it as defragmenting
your network traffic.
What we're really trying to do is use a combination
of different things: Prefetching, bundling,
basically trying to perform this big cookie
model, do as many things we can every time
we touch the Internet so that we reduce this
intermittent touching so we have less and
less time spent draining the battery.
Now, I'm going to explain how you can do that.
But, first of all, I just want to show you
exactly what I'm talking about.
This is the same data being transferred, the
same amount of data, but everything has been
batched together.
So those periodic pinnings, those Analytics
updates, you've just batched them up and I
only send them when I have something else
I need to do.
When they get sent isn't important.
Now, instead of having on-demand downloads
for the news articles, I'm going to prefetch
them.
I wrote this app, and I happen to know through
my Analytics data that people read exactly
two articles every minute and I happen to
know exactly which two articles those are.
So that's made it really easy for me to be
able to do this prefetching routine of two
articles a minute.
This is pretty contrived.
But it's actually contrived in a way that
makes it not as effective as it could be.
In a real-world solution, you can have this
window extend far further than the few seconds
that I have here.
But even with this contrived and basic solution,
you can see the impact is pretty dramatic.
Straightaway, you've gone from having no green
to having almost two-thirds green.
Even the active traffic has been reduced because
we're able to be much more efficient in the
way we download our data by doing it all in
one go.
So we've reduced both the active time and
the standby time so that we really are in
a much better situation here, where the app
is not going to be draining the battery for
anywhere near the amount of time that it was
before.
So how do we create these graphs?
How do we figure out what our app is doing
and how to make it better?
There are a number of tools available for
doing just that.
On the most basic level, you can use logcat.
So you can just print log statements before
and after you started doing your transfers,
potentially even keep track of how much data
you're transferring each time in order to
build up these graphs and this idea of how
your app is behaving.
Another option is the arrow tool, which is
a free open source tool available from AT&T,
who I think are actually demoing it out in
a sandbox.
You should stop by and say hi to them.
The advantage of their tool is that it's going
to produce graphs very much like the ones
I showed in the previous slide.
So they're going to show you your network
traffic and they're going to overlay your
radio state, specifically, the AT&T timings.
Another approach, which I actually quite like,
and this is more recently available, is the
network statistics tab in the DDMS view of
your Android developer tools.
That's the app that you can see here.
This colorful graph.
So this lets you tag different sockets, different
parts of your app so you can see how they're
all interacting, as you can here, using different
colors.
And you can do that using the traffic stats
class.
This is a relatively new class.
The beauty of all of this stuff is that you
can use it on your app even if you're targeting
early versions of Android.
You can do this analysis statically in the
emulator.
So you can do this for -- no matter what your
target is, even if you're not targeting later
versions of Android, you can still perform
the analysis.
So the way this works is, you simply assign
a tag to each of your output sockets.
They color code it, and you're able to see
exactly how your app interacts with other
components.
And you can look out for patterns, which I'm
going to go into a little bit more detail
on.
If you're not using sockets directly, if you're
using an HTTP client, then you can simply
set the thread stats tag on the thread itself,
and that will automatically be assigned to
the socket used by that HTTP client, making
life a little bit easier for you.
So now you've got the grass.
The next step is, what are you looking for.
So the first thing you're looking for is these
short spikes.
So this represents -- each of these spikes
is one second.
And so we're looking for both short in terms
of height and in duration, particularly duration.
Because here we are downloading for a second.
And each time we do that, the device is going
to be drawing battery for a minute, so that's
a really bad deal.
So you want to look for anything like that
and typically these are going to be good things
which can be delayed.
They can be bundled up.
They can be queued, so you can download them
in all in one go later.
Another really bad sign is anything periodic.
Anything which is happening on a set basis
because this stuff is basically guarantying
a minimum amount of time that your app is
going to be drawing power.
That's not what you want.
The minimum possible time that your app should
be drawing power from the cell radio is zero.
The user is doing nothing, it hasn't done
anything.
It shouldn't draw any power.
This is a really bad sign.
Slightly less concerning but still an area
that you can look to improve is these batches
of activities which happen in close proximity.
So here they are not unreasonable transfers
but there's this gap, this few seconds between
each of them.
And in that gap, we are still drawing battery,
so just by pushing them together, we can have
that incremental improvement.
So let's have a look at some solutions.
What can we do to try to improve this to defragment
our traffic?
One of those approaches is prefetching.
Now, what you've got to remember is that when
the cell radio, when the carrier are working
out what is the right timing for these tell
times, this is what they are trying to balance.
Minimize the latency and minimize the battery
life.
One plays off against the other.
They don't have a choice.
This is the graph they are on.
From our perspective, from our user perspective,
this is exactly the wrong graph.
We don't want that.
What we want is to hit this sweet spot.
Where we have got basically zero latency and
maximum battery life.
That's what we are trying to achieve.
Now, the idea of prefetching, you kind of
get the best of both worlds.
If it is already downloaded, it is already
processed, then you don't need to wait for
it to process it again.
At the same time, if you've prefetched it,
if you've bundled everything together, you
are not getting this spike, this intermittent
download, in the middle your app's life cycle.
It's already there, and you can much more
manage the frequency of those downloads.
Now, unfortunately, prefetching isn't a silver
bullet.
There is a risk.
There's a risk that you will download a bunch
of data that you don't need.
That's going to drain the battery just as
sufficiently or just as effectively.
So how do you make that balance?
Well, generally what you want to do is make
sure that whatever you are going to download
is going to be used by the app.
What you're trying to avoid doing is downloading
something that you know you are going to need
later so you do it ahead of time.
Typically, that is somewhere in the realm
of two to five minutes.
Now this depends on your app, the way that
it's used.
A lot of apps have sort of this two- to five-minute
window where they expect people to use them.
If you have something like a music player,
the window may be significantly longer.
The amount of data is also going to vary.
It's usually somewhere around one to five
megs, but this is going to vary on the cell
radio technology, its effectiveness, as well
as your app.
Practically speaking, if you've got something
like a music player, you probably want to
download the currently playing song in its
entirety and probably the next song as well,
but probably not the play list, probably not
the album.
All right?
If you have got a news app, you can be a lot
more aggressive.
We are talking about text.
Text is cheap.
You can download heaps.
You can download all the headlines and all
of your categories.
You know what, you should probably download
some of the article text as well.
You can either do this simplistically, say,
well, this is my front page, I'm just going
to start prefetching things based on when
they appear to the user.
You can be a little more clever and use Analytics.
70% of the people who use my app read these
articles.
I'm going to prefetch them for everyone.
Or make it more personal and say this user
always reads all the sports articles, I'm
going to pull them out.
Really, it's just a matter of trying to figure
out what is most likely to be used so I don't
have to pull it down later without pulling
down things that isn't going to be used.
I mentioned this is for 3G, these specific
timings.
The thing is, it changes depending on the
cell radio that you are using.
They have different efficiencies.
They have different speeds.
In this example, we will start with a default
based on a 3G network radio.
There's a lot of code here, but it's effectively
just a couple of switch statements.
All we are doing is checking, what is your
network technology.
If it's 4G, then we've got two things at play.
These radios, they tend to drain a little
more battery than their 3G equivalents.
They are also faster, so you can download
more over the same time period.
If you are trying to balance the cost of the
device going to be drawing current for a minute,
so I want to download for at least ten seconds,
you want to download more on a faster network.
The reverse is true for 2G.
It's slower.
It's slightly more energy efficient.
So you want to download less data.
Now, the specifics, I've gone times 4 times
2 is kind of arbitrary.
This is something you need to figure out within
your own experience what makes sense for your
data and for your app.
The key here is to remember it is going to
vary.
This is especially the case with Wi-Fi.
So on Wi-Fi you don't have a cell radio cost
associated with performing these downloads.
You can be much more aggressive.
In this example, I've simply said download
the maximum amount that we can to put in our
cache.
This is going to be much more dependent on
how much data do we want on the device, what's
the relative cost of processing, rather than
cost of putting things on the network.
So that's fine for apps, for data that we
know we are going to need.
You can prefetch things if you know eventually
it's going to have to happen.
But what do you do about things that happen
which are user initiated, things which you
don't know you are going to need ahead of
time because they are going to change because
the user has created them while they are using
the app.
The key here is to try and bundle them all
together.
You are trying to be as efficient as possible.
You're not -- you are bundling them, batching
them, you're doing whatever you can, trying
to make sure they aren't draining the battery
when you don't need them to.
One solution for that is to use a batch queue
for anything periodic.
So this is for things which user created by
aren't time sensitive.
So Analytics are a great example of this.
Anything where you don't need the server to
provide you a response, you just need to upload
it at some stage.
They work really well here.
So you can see, in this example, what we are
doing is every time we have something periodic,
which we want to send to the server, we will
add it to a queue, and then we are going to
execute that queue at a certain point.
You know importantly here, that when we do
execute that queue, when we transfer these
all these bundled periodic transfers, we will
also execute the next prefetch.
That may not be scheduled to happen for another
minute or two.
But hey, we have the radio turned on, why
not, right?
Do it all now.
Get it out of the way, and then we don't have
to turn the radio on again later.
The same thing is true when you have time-sensitive,
on-demand transfers.
So when your user is uploading a photo or
if you want to get feedback directly from
the server, it needs to happen then and there.
That's no reason not to bundle everything
else together as well.
So when you do have these time sensitive transfers,
you execute the next prefetch.
When you do that, you execute your periodic
transfers as well.
It all comes back to the same underlying philosophy.
Every time you touch the Internet, do everything
which you think you may need to do for the
next few minutes at once.
That's all good and well.
But what happens to the data that is server
side but you still need to get regularly updated?
So you have a news app and you want to get
new headlines or weather app and you need
to know what the current temperature is.
These are things which traditionally you're
going to do by polling.
How can we make this a more efficient process?
Fundamentally, we want to make it less frequent
and less regular to try to get away from the
bad patterns we have seen earlier.
First thing we can do is everyone's favorite,
inexact repeating alarms.
It wouldn't be I/O if I didn't present this
slide.
Basically, this will going to let the framework
do what we have been talking about for us.
It will phase shift our alarms so all the
downloads at the same time as other apps download
around a similar time frame.
Rather than each app waking up the device
every five minutes, it all happens at once.
This is a good start.
But it's pretty simplistic.
So what else can we do?
One approach is to use what I think of as
an inactivity back-off.
So what's happening here is we will set a
default for how often we should do our background
updates.
Now, if you've had to do this, you know this
is a balance.
This is a payoff where you are thinking, how
frequently can I do these updates so that
the data is as fresh as it can be but we are
not draining the battery by updating every
five minutes in the background.
It's always this balance.
What I'm suggesting we do here instead is
to say, well, let's start with that.
But if the user doesn't open the app since
the last time we have done a refresh, that
was wasted.
Let's wait twice as long next time.
They still haven't touched it, wait twice
as long again, so on and so forth.
If they exit it and never look at it again.
Hopefully that doesn't happen.
But if it does, your app isn't going to drain
the battery.
They don't have a reason to uninstall it.
I think this is a really good alternative
to trying to create that sort of -- that solution
where you are trying to find that balance.
So that's something we definitely should consider
as a default.
Obviously, it's always useful to have an option
for uses to manually set every fresh frequency,
to say, well, actually, I want it to be more
or less frequent than this.
But this is kind of a more efficient way of
being able to do that first step.
So I also mentioned early on that my retry
mechanism was overly simplistic.
It was inefficient.
I learned this the hard way.
A few years ago I built a widget for Google
desktop.
Anybody remember Google desktop?
What this did, it's great for a cricket info
website to get test match cricket scores.
As everyone knows, the fate of a match can
hinge on a single ball.
I had an aggressive update frequency of every
minute.
Every minute I would hit the server and scrape
the web page, find out the score.
I would look for a little string that would
say the match had completed at which point
I would stop doing my updates.
This worked really well.
I was a friend of mine who was beta testing
it at work.
He went home on a Friday before the match
finished.
By the time he came back on Monday, he got
the 404 page.
That's a pretty busy 404 page.
In fact, it's 131K of 404 page.
I was hitting that every minute for every
hour every day.
After a week, we've got one and quarter gig
of download which he discovered when the net
ops came past his desk to see if he was doing
bit parenting.
Imagine this on a mobile device.
4 gigs a month, that sounds -- or 5 gigs a
month.
That actually sounds a like the fair use quota
use for tariffs.
This isn't good.
If you have a simplistic 404 page or API which
returns with an error code, your data is going
to be a lot less but you're still doing periodic
updates, you're still going to drain the battery
just so the app knows something isn't working.
Not a good approach.
Solution here is that same back-off.
Exponential back-off.
Here I'm doing it using a recursive algorithm.
For your apps, you will want to use something
like alarms.
The key here is that, if it doesn't work,
wait twice as long next time and keep extending
that.
On a phone, you probably want to get to that
maximum interval, say, you know what, it's
not working, forget it, show something to
the user, do something within your app to
account for that.
There's no value in continuing to try something
that clearly isn't working.
Now, what's a better alternative to this background
polling, trying to make that more efficient,
is to use Google Cloud messaging instead.
This has been re-released now.
Eliminate polling completely if you have control
over the server.
So you just register your device to your server
into Google Cloud messaging.
Instead of you polling the server, the server
sends your device direct messages when it
has something to update.
This is so much more powerful because you're
no longer trying to figure out that balance
between how often should I ping the server
to check to see if there is something there
in order to provide fresh data.
You just get told by the server when there
is no data.
Then you can make a decision as to, do I want
to download that now.
Do I want to wait until the next prefetch
interval.
What is that data?
You can send all that information and provide
a much more efficient solution.
So I'm not going into too much detail.
The key to it is it is available back to Android
2.2, 94% of the devices.
In addition to all of these new features,
it has a significantly simpler authentication
story using API key.
So it is much easier to use on the server
side if you're not a server side developer,
which I'm not, so this was a big thing for
me.
It's -- actually the next session done in
room 9 downstairs is all about Google Cloud
messaging.
If it is of interest to you, it should be
if it isn't, definitely go and check that
out.
So this kind of goes without saying.
I'm going to say it anyway because it seems
fitting, redundant downloads are redundant.
Don't download anything you have already downloaded.
There's a few ways you can do that.
You want to make sure you filter anything
on the server.
Use APIs, which will let you say there is
the last piece of data that I got.
Or this is the last time I did my updates,
so only send me things more recent than that.
So that's kind of fundamental.
Then you're not having to process things,
not having to download things which you have
already downloaded in the past.
The same thing goes for any processing that
you are going to do on all of that data.
If you download an image and you're going
to display it as a 72 pixel thumbnail, there's
probably no reason to download the full wallpaper.
Much easier, more efficient for you to be
able to do that stuff on the server.
Much easier to throw resources on server side
solution than to hope all your users are going
to buy faster, better phones.
So anything you can do server side, do it
server side.
When you have downloaded it, make sure you
cache it.
Cache everything.
You have a couple of alternatives.
You can store it in the external cache.
Now this requires a new permission in Jelly
Bean to write to the external storage.
It's also (indiscernible) readable, so it's
kinda awesome.
If you use the internal cache, that's going
to be within your application sandbox, so
it's going to be controlled by you.
It's going to be also managed by the system,
which means if it becomes under resource pressure,
it's going to be able to clean out your cache
in order to save it some room.
This is the best approach.
Another thing you can do is make sure that
you don't download anything that you don't
have to.
So you can do that by inspecting the headers
of your http responses.
So you can check when does this data expire?
When was the last time it was updated?
Do I need to download the body here?
When should I try and update all of this information?
So that can be really useful.
Even better is that in Android 4.0 we introduced
a http response cache to the http URL connection
class.
So this is just using a reflection to turn
on a 10 meg cache on a http URL connection.
What this does is it is going to do all of
the stuff that I just explained for you.
It's going to create his own cache, inspect
the expired headings and every time you make
a request, it is going to check to see whether
it already has that data and whether or not
it has expired.
If it has it and it hasn't expired, it's just
going to serve you from the cache and put
it into the cache automatically for you.
This is a really neat trick to be able to
take away a lot of that hard work from you.
So that's almost done with efficiency.
If you want to have all of this information
without my strangely monotonic Australian
accent, it much easier copy/paste code snippets,
then you can get it all from the developer
training site at developer.android.com/training.
It will be all there for you.
I've spoken in this section about efficiency,
specifically about battery life, specifically
about the cell radio.
Jeff Sharkey is doing a session in this room
at 4 o'clock today which is going to cover
a whole bunch of other efficiency things you
can do with CPU, with memory, with I/O, definitely
check that out.
So we have a few minutes left.
I've got one last section, this will be the
shortest.
[ Video ]
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: Relatability is something we
all want.
If your power stops power your devices, if
your water starts running, it's kind of a
big deal.
But if it works, you just totally ignore it.
And that's exactly what you want.
You want to be able to take these sorts of
things for granted.
So how can you do that?
How can you create an app which is properly
reliable.
So part of that is static analysis.
You can use tools like Lint, like strict mode
will let you have a look at how your apps
are working.
I kind of like to think of these as a lot
like a peer review.
Someone who already knows all of the right
stuff, probably the same stuff as you, maybe
a little bit more, and they are able to give
you code a look over to tell you whether or
not you are doing the right thing.
Now, so, yeah, basically a peer review but
without the self-loathing and recriminations
that so often accompany a good peer reviewing.
Once you get past that though, you really
need to see how your app is going to work
on devices, that means buying devices.
There's thousands of Android devices, certainly
no one is going to expect anyone to buy all
of them, certainly Google hasn't.
So what is an alternative solution?
Well, one thing from talking to developers
trying to solve this problem is find ways
to separate that market.
Now, what I've done here are separated into
buckets in terms of screen size and screen
resolution.
Now, this is no longer the way that you should
be designing your screen layouts.
You are not trying to design screen layouts
in terms of these buckets.
You are trying to use minimum screen widths
and make sure that you create an app that
scales within those bounds.
But in terms of choosing apps, choosing devices
to test your apps, this is actually still
a pretty good approach.
So you are now down to 16 buckets.
As you choose each of the devices from that,
you want to try and create something that
is as varied as possible.
So you want to get devices with different
GPUs, different manufacturers, some which
have cameras, some which have slide-out keyboards,
touch screens, et cetera, et cetera, and that
will give you a nice cross-section to test
with.
That's kind of still a lot of devices.
So if your budget is a little bit more limited,
you can kind of focus on the areas which are
going to represent the largest part of your
audience.
So you can see here that that pretty much
comes down to smartphones and ten-inch tablets
at the moment.
This is based on the numbers on the Android
developer site.
And that will give you a pretty good coverage,
right?
That's only three devices.
The only problem here is that you're actually
possibly limiting yourself.
What comes next?
These are the devices that are out there now.
But you all have Nexus 7s now.
At $199, I feel there will be a bunch these
devices in people's hands.
Plus all the new smartphones are running XH
DPI so the Galaxy Nexus, HTC1X, Samsung Galaxy
X3, they are all running these extra high
res displays.
While this is a little bit of guesswork, you
can usually take a pretty good guess as to
where the next big buckets are going to be
and perhaps invest in those as well.
You guys are lucky, you've already have those
last two buckets given to you today.
So that's going to make life a little bit
easier.
So you've done your testing on your hardware.
I did mention that that's not the right way
to do multiple screens.
The right way to do multiple screens is on
the developer.android.com training site, so
do check that out.
Beyond that, for the devices you haven't got,
use monkey runner.
Use the emulator.
Try out as many variations as you can.
Get alpha testers.
Get people who you know.
Don't get your smartest techy friends.
Get your least techy friend.
The guy who you have to help him get his phone
out the Swahili every other week.
That is the guy who is going to find the edge
cases, push 7 buttons at the same time and
wonder why it broke.
That's the person who you want testing your
apps.
So, if there's anything we've learned from
IO this year and the keynote yesterday, is
that Android is a lot more than a smartphone
development platform.
Certainly the huge, huge user base of smartphones
means it's going to be the focus for a lot
of us.
But with new devices like these tablets, like
the Transformer Prime and the Nexus 7, we
are seeing this increasing ecosystem.
If you guys have had a chance to hack around
with your Nexus Q, you see the potential is
that this ecosystem is going to grow further
to devices more and more varied, more and
more different.
But fundamentally, hopefully, if you create
an app that uses the achievements of invisibility,
efficiency, and reliability, you will create
something so that it doesn't matter what users
are using, which device they are operating
with.
They are not using the Internet on their phone,
they are using your app.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: So then we barely have enough
time for a couple questions.
Before we dive into that.
I wanted to give a quick rundown on what I
used to provide this presentation today.
I got a lot of questions about that last year.
I'm actually using two devices over here.
You have a Nexus 7 and a Transformer Prime.
I've hooked them up so that the Transformer
Prime is doing all of work.
I have a HGMI cable which goes up to the projector.
My clicker plugs into it.
I have an Internet connection to send off
stuff to the social networks and I have a
Nexus 7 over here which is where my speaker
notes are.
Today actually they hooked it up so it shows
up on my conference monitor down there.
So, yeah, we do have a couple of minutes.
So questions?
There's mics down the aisle.
>>> Check check.
Thank you for your presentation.
And I'm Bo Stone from Bo Stone Consulting.
So here's the question.
Is there an easy way to detect that the radio
is, in fact, on and so would it make sense
to check that before I do that batching that
you were referring to?
>>Reto Meier: That's a good point.
That's something that would be useful.
There aren't any APIs at the moment that allow
you to say perform this the next time the
radio is on.
You basically want something like the passive
location provider but for transfers.
Unfortunately, no, there's no API for that
at the moment.
>>> Maybe you guys will add it in the future.
>>Reto Meier: Definitely something to hope
for.
>>> Thank you.
>>Reto Meier: No problem.
>>> Hi, can you comment on the CPU battery
life trade-off of compressing a text file
before sending it versus sending it uncompressed?
>>Reto Meier: That's a good question.
So I think the battery life impact on doing
that compression is going to be pretty negligible.
The processing cost of that is going to be
pretty slow whereas when you are doing that
transfer, like not only is it a shorter amount
of time, it is less pressure on the networks
themselves.
Big part of that as well.
I focused on the efficiency side.
Talk to the carriers, it's really important
for them to get payloads as small as possible,
let the networks more efficiency.
That's going to end up in a much better result
in your uses as well.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Thanks for the presentation.
Regarding the earlier part of the presentation,
do you have any idea if Google Analytics pays
attention to sort of all your recommendations?
>>Reto Meier: That is a good question.
So the existing Analytics SDK allows you to
dispatch your Analytics information whenever
you want to.
So that allows you to have that control.
I think it's something that I've just actually
been having conversations with them now to
find out exactly what they do and what they
don't do in terms of automated downloads.
Something they are aware of.
We will go from there.
>>> Cool, thanks.
>>> My name is Rob.
I want to know if the http response cache
class is useful for caching images or just
for small http responses because I found caching
images especially with, like, downloading
background threads to be a really challenging
problem when you are downloading a lot of
things at once.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Downloading images is definitely a challenge.
I would say the http response cache, I had
to practice a long time to be able to say
that.
It probably could work but it's probably not
the most efficient way to deal with that,
so there's -- I think we talked in the fireside
chat yesterday that there is a library which
we will be releasing at some point that try
to say do it in the most effective way.
There's an Android training class as well.
>>> I am really looking forward to that library.
>>Reto Meier: I think you are not the only
one.
>>> So you comment to use Cloud messaging
service to push messages, right?
But I'm wondering, so particularly a window
sign into any -- so what is the plan for those
little percentages of user who don't sign
into any account.
So what is the plan that -- how we can push
messages to that user.
>>Reto Meier: That's a good question.
I'm not a hundred percent sure on the answer
here.
You will want to check with the GCM team who
are doing a talk next.
I have a suspicion that GCM doesn't require
a sign-in, it requires the GMS services to
be on the device.
>>> You mean to say this is different from
C2DM, shore for user sign-in.
>>Reto Meier: C2DM did.
I'm not certain, so please do check with the
team.
I have a suspicion that that may have already
been solved.
>>> Maybe you can give me some contact.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Come out to the office hours and we will hook
you up with the right people.
>>> Hi Reto, great session.
>>Reto Meier: Thank you.
>>> Are you aware Google http library which
also does exponential back-off, retry handling,
caching, would you recommend that for development
in Android?
I think it's compatible with Android run times.
>>Reto Meier: No, I'm not family familiar
with it, so I can't really comment.
That's usually a good sign, but I couldn't
say.
I'd have to look into it before giving an
opinion.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[ Applause ]